hey guys today it is World Mental Health
Day and since mental health it's a cause
very close to my heart I thought I'd let
you know that if you decide to pick up
hell-blade today all the proceeds are
going to a mental health charity in the
UK so why not pick it up I'm Dan I'm Joe
and it's guess what news done
at the end of one of our stories
yesterday we told you that the SNES mini
classic is going to be easier to get
than the NES mini classic and it looks
like thing taking game stock we're about
to get their next shipments
starting today game stop and think ik
retail locations will begin receiving
shipments of the highly sought console
game stuff should have their full
allotment late Thursday October 12th and
the units will be sold standalone for 80
bucks no crazy extras like last time
tomorrow both retailers will start
selling their latest allotment online in
both standalone and bundle form if
you're set on grabbing one make sure
you're quick as these are guaranteed not
to last
and remember Nintendo has pledged more
consoles this time around and we'll be
shipping them well into 2018 so do not
buy scalped consoles if you're looking
for something music in destiny to Lilith
Paladin as the iron banner have returned
to the tower the PvP focused event pits
teams of four Guardians against each
other to win you limited time armor and
gear there's also a new map distant
Shore for you and your fire team to run
around destiny choose iron banner
functions a little differently from the
first game level advantages are disabled
this time around it so now it's all
about skill this time around the game
mode will be control so make sure to
take those points to open the iron
banner you'll need to have completed the
campaign and have a chat to Lord Saladin
in the tower once done you can enter the
mode through the crucible playlist
finally Ubisoft have revealed what's in
store for Assassin's Creed origins
aparts to launch content there's gonna
be two major expansions and a bunch of
small add-on - some of which are going
to be free the first DLC pack is called
the hidden ones it's due to launch in
January of next year and is set many
years after the base game as you clash
with the Romans in a new region the
second DLC pack the curse of the
Pharaohs will be out in March and
introduces a quote new mystical realm in
which you'll encounter beasts such as
Anubis warriors Scorpios and more as you
investigate the curse that is
resurrected dead Pharaohs both story
expansions are included in the $40
season pass which also packs into
smaller add-ons containing new outfits
weapons and 500 in-game credits you
might remember from our earlier stories
on Assassin's Creed origins that there
are a ton of special editions to choose
from six in fact so if you want to know
precisely what you'll get in each check
out our story on games but aside from
the paid DLC content Ubisoft are also
planning to add free content which will
include a photo mode and head
summers and a horde mode that is
everything we've got for you guys today
do let us know what he cared about down
in that comment box and we will see you
again tomorrow
[Music]
you